oh I want to talk about the suit for
farting lady is me my lawyer will sing
because she made what I think is a false
claim she said I didn't just fart on her
which I already disagree with I farted
all over her did you catch that
just watch it again oh sorry excuse me
excuse me I'm sorry I bumped it on
purpose on me oh no no I don't I
wouldn't bump any on purpose no even
bump you farted on me give me your your
information my lawyer will sue you your
lawyer will sue me yes for bumping into
your car no we farted out over me and my
lawyer will see you believe it or not
people actually ask me like how far that
went
did it did it actually go to court did I
give her my information the answer is no
although I would have loved for this to
go to court this would have been the
best court case in history imagine that
the poor guy the judge that worked his
whole life to get to where he is just to
hear the case of the lady that got
farted on in Walmart by me would have
been amazing Your Honor my client was
humiliated that man farted all over her
the judge I think the look on his face
would just be this how do you react to
something like that and the greatest
part though of the scenario I think is
the de jurors they would have to watch
the tape in court it would be the most
fun anyone ever had in a courtroom ever
and the best part is if the jury laughs
I'm home free so know that that never
actually went to court thank goodness
this went on three full times did it not
MUC is this right ladies and gentlemen
Jack vales mom